former ESPN colleague and also the host
of her own podcast on Spotify called
Jamel Hill is unbothered from the
Atlantic as well good to see you
Jamel Hill good to be here I feel like
once since leaving ESPN I've picked up
17 more job well that's the way I mean
interesting thing is that ESPN you had
17 jobs right but it was just under 1
now you're a - it right now you're a
conglomerate you're your own you're your
own brain yeah you are your own bread I
mean you're wearing your own branded
material right now the only one who has
their name in the show you know what
that's the idea to do it that is the
idea to do how many people still think
though that you're on ESPN was still a
lot and I especially love the people
like an airport or on a plane or a you
know on a flight who say oh yeah I watch
your show all the time I was I do you
the last thing I said it just just
really curious cuz I haven't been there
since September I'll tell you Jamel I'll
tell the story I've told it before
Brockman you've heard about 19 million
times I feel like you're you're like my
wife Suzy like oh god here comes a story
again but when I left ESPN the all-star
game the NBA all-star game was here in
Staples my wife was working for the
local of Fox Sports regional and she
covered the Lakers for all those years
so we went to the event and I'm there
and she's working I'm chilling out some
guy comes up to me says I'm watch your
show every day and I had left ESPN
months before and I'm on NFL Network
which is on only in about 12 million
homes thanks to DirecTV that was it and
I said the same thing oh did you really
you watch NFL Network goes what are you
talking about because you're not on ESPN
anymore I'm like no I'm the guy pause
and he goes are you alright I'm like I
could fog up a mirror for you right now
but so many people you know think that
if you've left ESPN it's not a good
thing but I would beg to obviously
differ with something like that I mean I
think a lot of people understandably so
they look at ESPN as the the pinnacle
job in sports media that's the
destination job that's where you want to
end up
and there's nothing wrong with that
dream ESP endo was never a place that
was on my vision board I never got into
this profession thinking I have to wind
up on TV I have to wind up on
SportsCenter those are things that just
evolved once I got there the thing I
always wanted to do and to be was a
writer and I spent you know more than
half of my career as a print reporter
and so that was my main focus so I guess
because I was never one of these people
who felt like they had to be on
television every day leaving TV wasn't
that hard I mean I'm not retired from it
right um I'm just more or less very
picky about what I do and thinking about
it in a much different way than I did
when when I was there but it was never
really my dream to be a sports in her
anchor in fact it was probably not
probably it was the worst job that I had
at ESPN what do you mean come on oh I
know you see I feel so terrible saying
that somebody is a great by the way I
don't take it personally at all but the
six o'clock that you did was a totally
different write a show than a highlight
driven event that that I was part of
many many moons ago at eleven o'clock or
at 2:00 in the morning I mean there's so
much going on and they were also trying
to reinvent the show with you at the
same time yeah it was a lot going on and
you know people have to understand that
when I first when I stepped through the
door to Ed ESPN it was in the commentary
lane and that was the lane that I was in
and Sports Center it was always an
awkward fit because that is a show to
tell you it means the evening news is
sports so while there's no new
highlights to show you because you're on
a 6 p.m. Eastern
you know the fact is your job is mostly
to update people on what's happening and
what's about to happen in terms of that
night but there were all these
conversations that were taking place in
sports that I wanted to be a part of
that I really couldn't in that role and
so it was never the perfect fit and as
you said they were trying to evolve the
show there was a lot of creative
differences in terms of what the show
should be and so it while I learned a
lot and certainly learned a lot about
television and anchoring because it was
a fire drill every night at SportsCenter
tends to be it just it was yeah it was
the worst job I had since I was there no
kidding yeah so now what do you like
about what you got going on
well what I love and as somebody who's
been and planted firmly in the podcast
lane is being able to sit down talk to
really interesting people have you know
great conversations and not be limited
to sports because there's a lot of other
things that I'd love to talk about so
you don't have to stick to sports so
it's a it talked about funny comments I
always think it's hilarious when people
because you know writing for the
Atlantic when they say oh why can't you
just talk about sports perhaps you don't
know the publication that I'm running
for right now probably think it's the
athletic yes because a lot of people did
get that confused at first but the
Atlantic I wanted to write in particular
about the you know the intersection
between sports race culture and gender
and they created a space for me to do
that on the Spotify podcast that's
something totally different I mean we
could talk about the Game of Thrones
finale as well as talk about you know
the upcoming presidential election
sports culture news politics so it just
allows me to play him any more areas I
mean but we just saw a picture of you
with Berkeley and Stacey Abrams together
I mean that's pretty much in one
photograph what you're talking about
what sort of contact what's so funny is
that the people you know of course
people might expect a conversation about
sports from Berkeley we spent a lot of
times we spent a lot of that podcast you
know trying to solve racism in America
we got to do a little more to do stacey
abrams and i what I didn't realize
before this podcast and as I was doing
research is she's written nine romance
novels so we talked a lot about romance
writing are you serious yes yes she's a
she's written like thriller romance
novelist under a pseudonym and so she
really has a real passion for writing
which I can obviously appreciate so Wow
sure we talked about voter suppression
and how she dealt with the aftermath of
not winning the gubernatorial race but
we spent a lot of it talking about
writing and Game of Thrones tell me her
pseudonym was Danielle Steele I hate
that I can't remember what it is
never been something so I was also gonna
ask if Stacey Abrams gave any thoughts
on whether Kevin Durant has already made
up his mind for free a big decision to
make of her own no she didn't offer any
any thoughts on that Barkley had some
thoughts on that as well as magic
because at the time when we did the
podcast he had just quit so it was
everybody was still trying to figure out
what the hell well actually do we do we
have that I mean that's the only way to
get into this conversation here with
Jamel here Jill Jamel here Jamel Hilary
were on the Rich Eisen show is basically
with Stephen a Smith had to say when
magic was there on first take on Monday
interestingly enough when when the same
day that Frank Vogel was being
introduced as head coach you have a J
what what the hell happened are you
allowed to say something bad about magic
being or being critical not bad about
anybody especially now that live in LA
is like double pressure right I don't
know I think the way sometimes the way
you leave a job says everything about
how you felt about your time at that job
okay and the way that he left indicated
to me that there was a lot of issues I
was shocked that he left in that regard
given what we think we know about his
relationship with with Jeannie but what
he says is that relationship relation
right but that's that's the kind of way
you leave somebody after a bitter
breakup after somebody cheated okay
that's not you that's how he left that
job trail or betrayal and was the word
as he indicated on first take it was the
backbiting I think the fact that he felt
as if his authority was never was always
undermined and that he never really had
the authority that he had that he was
able to leave but he didn't say that
at that press conference right that was
going down as you were interviewing
Barkley on your pod yeah he didn't say
that he said the reason why he didn't
fire Luke Walton and the reason why he's
leaving is he's not that guy he's the
magic who wants to just call up Dwayne
Wade and say congratulations or
tweet at Russell Westbrook he's that
that's the guy he wanted a big he didn't
say I don't have the power here and I
want to be the president of the Lakers
and I have no ability to do this so and
I brought that up to see Webb yesterday
and see Webb goes he made it look like
instead of it being two completely
different points of view and evolution
of somebody who couldn't speak his mind
on the day that he left to able to
gather his thoughts hearing what people
were saying about him and show up on
first take either at the worst possible
time for the Lakers or sure enough the
same day where Frank Vogel is named and
Rob poulenc is the one trying to turn
the page publicly for the team so we in
a trust tree we in the nest here right
okay so I'm sure that the thoughts that
I had right after I left the ESPN versus
what I would say now are different still
the same story and is this is not to say
that I have a bunch of bad things to say
about ESPN but it is to say like how I
just told you about how sports and it
was the worst job that I had there I
didn't say that eight or nine months ago
but I just said it now and so I'm saying
true I'm saying all this to say and this
is not to absolve magic do I think he
should have left in a better way
absolutely especially if you have the
relationship that you say that you have
now maybe they caught him at the wrong
moment in the sense that he was ticked
off about everything happening he was
still trying to put a bit of a happy
face on it and trying to do some some
spin control so that he didn't make the
or didn't throw all of the organization
under the bus but he alluded to then
that there was some backstabbing that
was happening she did not say who it was
we just all assumed now the only
difference though between your analogy
and the magic one other than the
Michigan State stuff is is you didn't
profess and still don't profess to have
a sibling type relationship with Bob
Iger know that's the thing that don't
understand is okay you want the best for
Jeanie bus you keep saying that Ramona
she'll burn your former colleague at
ESPN reports that Jeanie asked magic not
once but twice off-camera
obviously privately what do I need to
know and magic both times essentially
sit no we're good
you don't know anything and then shows
up and tell Steven Naismith something
that he wouldn't tell her so I mean I
also another relationship I analyze in
in which shapes my perspective is
looking at some of the other beefs if
you will that magic has had look at the
one with him in Isaiah and how
complicated that was gosh yes for years
they told two completely different
stories about what happened and who said
what and Isaiah this was years ago even
told me at a Super Bowl we were we were
at a Super Bowl party that he was just
as shocked when magic let it be known
that there was still existing beef
because he had talked about how recently
or he told me recently he had seen magic
and that everything was fine and then he
you know I think it might have been
around the time that the bird the book
that he did with burger came out and he
was stunned that some of that
information was in the book so I don't
know if this is just you know magic when
you're when your nickname is magic and
you're known for being happy and smiling
and always being the guy bringing folks
together if that makes it harder for you
sometimes when there's conflict to tell
people how you really feel because to
some degree you're worried about your
persona and that's not to call magic
fake or anything like that but I'm not
surprised that if it's a little bit more
complicated for him in his position
Jamel Hill here on the Rich Eisen show
of what do you think about Kawhi Leonard
in Toronto what we saw last night what
we've seen from the Warriors - Kevin
Durant do you think either one of these
guys has the notion that they're gonna
be staying put
come July first I do I mean if you're
Kawhi Leonard I don't know how the city
the organization the success has not
made an impression on you people are
treating this like it's some foregone
foregone conclusion the City of Toronto
I think very much fits his personality I
mean and I think right now what we're
seeing from him we always knew Kawhi was
a great defender a high effort player
but I think we've been exposed to just
how
much heart he has and that's again not
to say that he didn't show any in San
Antonio but because this truly is a
hundred percent his team we're seeing
emotion from him and things from him I
don't think that we've seen before and I
don't know I would I think it goes you
know a lot of people always say when you
always said when he was coming in that
like there's no way that he would stay
but again like I think they've shown him
a lot like unless he just wants to be in
LA or wants to be in another city or you
know wants to play for a specific
organization I think the the Lal is
there Kevin Durant I would be stunned if
he's in the Golden State uniform next
year I would be stunned
it just feels just in his energy and
comments he said and I know he hasn't
said a whole lot and even in some of the
little mini arguments and many dramas
that have played out with that team all
season it just feels like he's ready to
move on alright let me get into this
with you a little bit here cuz I've I've
said the exact opposite I don't and I'm
not the type and as you know and to sit
in the chair like this and I'm gonna
take the exact opposite right so I can
get a click or people saying did you
hear what that guy said so it comes down
to July 1st you're sitting in a room
you're Kevin Durant and you see the
Knicks and I love Fez Dale I think that
that's their ace in the hole as far as
I'm concerned certainly with the owner
and how I feel about the owner and the
rest of the management team there their
pitch to him is come to New York you
could own New York we're gonna see if we
can get Kyrie we're gonna draft RJ
parrot we got a lot of young guys you
walk into the door in Los Angeles at the
Clippers and you see Steve Ballmer and
he's nuts but you know he's he's all in
Doc Rivers is one of the best in the
business
he's a coach of the year finalist right
now and then there's the guy who's on
the logo who was the one who told him go
to Golden State and Jerry West and say
see how I kind of get you JD and then he
goes to Golden State and then there's
Steve Kerr there's curry right there's
the Hamptons five back together and same
let's run it back
and they're sitting in this beautiful
haptens this time but in this beautiful
jewel that will bond said he visited a
couple weeks ago it's the most amazing
thing on planet Earth yeah it's an easy
decision all comes down and rubber meets
July first Road that's why I don't get
the whole like he's got to find his own
thing
well I think a lot of it has to do with
not just that desire to kind of create
something on his own it seems like him
and LeBron are destined to have mirror
ways their career has gone how things
played out for him at Oklahoma City was
how things played out for LeBron the
first time he was in Cleveland then he
went to Miami to figure out how to win
katie is in Golden State figuring out
how to win what it means to be a
championship to get that that monkey
that albatross off of him that he hadn't
won okay now he's got multiple
championships next step is proving to
people with all that he's learned in
these last couple stops that he can do
it on a team that's built around him his
personality he doesn't have to share
anything
I think the negativity that he
experienced and go to and when he went
to Golden State I still think that's a
factor it bothers him and because it
bothers him so much that he started a
burner account and went through all
those things that lets me know that he
is ready to move on because he'll never
really get the credit that he deserves
now he shouldn't care about what people
say on social media but that's easier
said than done when you're getting waves
of it all the time where people are
doubting whether or not you can do this
on your own and considering you a
front-runner because you went and joined
another team that had already won 72
games and all that other nonsense to me
he made the right decision I would love
to see him stay because I like greatness
and I want to see how many titles can
this core group of players win but at
the same time you know I think KD is
also thinking about you know am I better
off being away from this organization
and and submitting myself further as a
historic players well Jamel Hill here on
the Rich Eisen show let me just take
this one step further is that you
mentioned Game of Thrones before maybe
Kevin Durant is
what you talking about mirroring LeBrons
career and is about to try and break the
wheel
because if not him he's trying to break
the wheel because with all due respect
to LeBron the situation he's in right
now where he went and his last or his
third act in a way after learning how to
win and winning is showing up to a
Tiffani name brand name of a sports
organization with a front office that
has nothing but dumpster fire being
talked about it and just because you
roll out the red carpet and say hey
we're the Lakers that doesn't bring
somebody there that sounds like the
Knicks to me mm-hmm
that sounds like if direct so your brain
right now you're basically trying to do
have the best story I'd like to say so
much so that's what to me again when it
all comes down to it it's gonna be an
amazing July first for the NBA amazing
I think Durant stays put maybe Kawhi
dozen carries looking where do I go and
maybe he winds up here runs it back with
LeBron and I think the Lakers would go
[Music]
right now circle story I mix wouldn't
like it but I think that that that's
that's that's the way July 1st seems to
me I would know why comes to the
Clippers another great option for him
but I again like you to me it seems like
a very I wouldn't say easy decision but
it just seems like the Golden State
still has the best case I think he
should worry less about the people who
feel as if he cheated the system and got
the cheat code by going to Golden State
who cares about those people as I've
often said is you know we've become so
much a championship or bust Society you
can't blame players for chasing rings
when that's all people seem to value so
he really put himself in the best
basketball situation and how many times
I hope he thinks about this how many
times are you gonna play with a cast
that's that great and so selfless you
know Steph Curry is probably one of the
most selfless superstars ever the most
unassuming selfless Superstore period
yeah he has no problem him or clay or
draymond any of them have no problem and
meeting and professing that Kevin Durant
is their best player despite all they've
done and one together that's a unique
situation coach - yeah it's a very
unique situation and why would you leave
it Hey while the circumstances are much
different but I mean it even though it
was the torture for me as a Pistons fan
but when the Bulls they just broke up
for nothing
this would feel like so you're just
breaking up for for what and I mean I
think go and say couldn't win you know
without him they still have a lot of
major pieces in place but especially if
they get to this finals I mean they are
in the final sorry but if if he isn't
able to play in the finals and they
still win I mean I think that's another
reason why that pushes him out the door
let's change a narrative I I agree on
that okay so check you out in the
Atlantic for the written word and the
spoken word on the podcast Jamel Hill is
unbothered on Spotify and then on
Twitter and Instagram at gmail he'll
very simple thanks for coming on
thanks man stick around one more
television only segment if you don't
mind I got one thing we want to ask you
about
that's Jamel Hill here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app